Patrick and Francis Connolly from Moira
a little Tyne
we're kinda ARMA meets County Dean are
not just millionaires but millionaires
115 times over and they are with us now
Francis how did you discover that you
had won this extraordinary amount of
money well I didn't Patrick did and he
sort of checked it three or four times
before he told me at all and he said I
think we've I'll give you have you do
you want some good news that's what he
said
and I saw that the lottery ticket was
open I thought oh we must have want a
wee bit of money but few thousand maybe
or something and I said oh how much did
we won he said no you misunderstand me
we've won and I thought a few expletives
later Annie I thought he was joking I
said I wouldn't joke about something
like this and that was it that was how I
find out it how do you begin to spend
one hundred and fifteen million pi oh my
god I make a good stab at it I promise
but yeah it's it's an incredible amount
of money it really is and it's actually
beyond you know that the conversations
you have about what would you do if you
won the lottery and all those that
everybody has over the kitchen table we
will promise everybody we will
definitely do all those things but when
we first find out it was just we stared
at each other for about ten minutes that
was that with no jumping up and down and
we started to make a list of all the
people that we want to help it's really
interesting to hear that you want to
make more millionaires and you spoke
earlier at the press conference about
wanting to help charity but has there
never been one thing one luxurious item
that you thought I really want to buy if
I have enough money to do it oh I'm
having a new car
what type of car X type jag are you
going to travel the world a bit oh yes
we are going to do all those things but
genuinely we haven't really thought
about them since this happened we're
basing it all on the plans that we made
when we didn't think we were you know
like I say over the kitchen table so
we're assuming we'll get back to them
and we will do all of those Patrick what
was life like before
he chose those seven winning numbers
were you struggling to pay the bills
were you like everyone else figuring out
how are we going to deal with the credit
card after Christmas like we're normal
people and hardworking people I've
always worked so yes you're always be
conscious of it you're always thinking
about saving for your daughters in their
future this just puts us in a league
that we didn't even dream of you know
and I think you're going to continue
doing the lottery every week is that
right of course yeah I mean I had a
minute we're only the fourth biggest
winner I always want to be number one so
yeah we'll continue doing it have you
shared this good news with your family
you've got three children and three
grandchildren and how did how did they
respond we've told the children the
grandchildren the brothers and sisters
my dad and some of our closest friends
we're really we this happened so quickly
we wanted to phone everybody and tell
them ourselves but we just the this bets
the press but happened so much quicker
than we thought we didn't have time to
tell everybody so really sorry about
that not one single person believed us
they or everybody did a version of Ag
away you're jokin you know lots of
people following your story have tweeted
me today to say that they would never in
a million years dream of going public if
they won this amount of money why did
you make the decision to go public well
we are one of those people as well we
would wanted to stay private we didn't
actually tell even our daughters until
the papers were saying yesterday morning
we told nobody and we really really were
trying to figure out if we could to keep
it quiet we have fifty people on a list
that we are going to give money to we
have not even finished with that we want
to do good deeds with the money we want
to help businesses in Northern Ireland
and in the northeast of England we want
we want to do a lot of things for a lot
of people and there was we could not
figure a way out of how this was
to stay quiet other ways it most
definitely would have stayed quiet